hails of guys my name is a cello and
welcome to episode 4 of the utilization
miniseries so today we're going to be
talking about binary and particularly
bitwise operators and what not so this
is a very important episode for things
to come and it's also more of a
standalone episode as well so this is
going to apply to all of you who don't
understand bitwise operators and who
want to and who need to it's a very
important part of programming that's
that everyone should really know and it
will make your life a lot easier in
penny circumstances but it's definitely
needed for something like civilization
because right now we're dealing with
converting things to and from binary ok
and doing so requires four wise
operators most of the time ok so we're
going to just cover all of them we're
going to see some examples and whatnot
and hopefully you'll hopefully you'll be
able to understand them perfectly by the
end of this video all right let's get
right into it so the first of the
operators that we have right that I want
to talk about is the and operated the
bitwise and operator and the bitwise or
operator so and as shown as an ampersand
which I'm just gonna draw like that and
then the or is just a pipe ok so it's
straight line so let's talk about and
real quick this this is basically like a
kind of logical and right so when you
have two states let's just say one is
true and what is false remember this is
binary so really you and they have ones
and zeros to deal with so if you have
these obviously if you had a just normal
if statement there's something like if
true and false the result would be false
right because they need to both be true
if there's an ad there because the end
says that if if like a and B are true
then you play result
right so it's exactly the same thing
with binary if you do something like 1
and 0 obviously that's going to give you
0 ok if you try and add one and one
together you're going to get 1 ok 0 and
0 are obviously going to give you 0
because they're both false and finally 0
one is going to be the same as one and
zero and just give you zero okay so
really both of the sides of the equation
need to be the same pretty much or true
in order to get a like a true result
okay so the applications of this are
going to come to light soon I'm just
getting the basic explanations out of
the way or is kind of almost the
opposite where it's essentially like an
or in in in a normal logical if
statement right where you have something
like 1 or 0 of course will be 1 because
either of these have to be true for the
result to be true okay
1 or 1 is also going to be correctly 1
okay 0 or 0 well in this case really you
can't make a 1 out of nothing so this is
gonna be 0 because both of them are are
false right
and finally 0 or 1 of course is going to
be 1 as well so you can see that we get
much more ones here whereas in ends you
know they both have to be true in here
only one side of the equation or one
side of the statement has to be true
okay cool so that's and and all there
are also some other operations that we
really need to look at I don't think
we'll be using it in this series but I
will cover them anyway we've got XOR saw
and not ok so this in Java looks like a
little hat and in most languages as well
and a squiggly line or a flail as I like
to call it it's like a tilde is for
naught okay so what does this mean and
how does this work well XOR is kind of
XOR is kind of let's draw this up XOR is
kind of like or except with one big
difference okay so XOR actually stands
for exclusive or okay so it means that
one of these has to be true but not both
of them okay so the way we can do that
is say that if either of these are true
which you can see only one of them is
true right not either of these so either
of these would be or one of these
exactly one of these would be
X alright so because of one of these is
unique essentially because one of these
is one but the other one isn't this
returns a true result okay so basically
the only difference from the ore is if
we have something like one axle one
that's going to give us a zero because
then they're the same okay
so zero or zero is also going to give us
a zero of course and zero or one is
going to give us one okay so you can see
it's like all but the one one or one is
replaced with the zero result nos is
something that works on that isn't
really part of an equation it's more or
less something that you pass in to a
number what I mean by that is that
typically you wouldn't do you can't it's
something like one not one or something
it doesn't make any sense so you just
stick it it's in front of something so
like not zero and not one so what this
will do is it will basically reverse
it'll invert the bits okay so this
highly the number that you get for it
from here highly depends on how big your
number is in terms of how many bits are
in the number because when I say
something like this right the number
might be if we're dealing with like an
integer it's going to be 32 bits right
so if you invert zero you're going to
get the 32 bit version and also just
once right so in this case if we're just
dealing with a 1 bit number this of
course will give us 1 and this will give
us 0 okay so it just inverts it again
not something that's particularly useful
for this it is generally quite a useful
operation it's it's great for like
flipping States and flipping flags and
whatnot when you're trying to deal with
bit fields I've suddenly used for that
and it's been pretty useful but yeah we
probably don't need to look at it too
much in depth these two though we will
look at some real world applications and
whatnot
ok the final thing you really need to
know is something called bit shifting ok
so bit shifting we have two operators
for that we've got the left shift and
we've got the right shift okay these are
again very simple all they do is shift
the binary value a select number of
places ok so if we have something like
zero one zero zero in binary which was
course would be the number four if we've
got something like this and we decide to
shift it left one one spot essentially
that's going to give us one zero zero
zero as you can see we've literally
taken this guy and we've just shifted it
one place to the left okay this place is
always in bits of course not bytes or
anything so if you want to shift it one
byte you just write eight over here okay
this is cutting the other way around if
we had the number four and we decided to
shift it right one space we wind up with
zero zero one zero as you can see it's
shifted right one space now if you were
clever enough you probably would notice
that this was four right and it became
it became eight when we shifted it and
then when this was four it became too
when we shifted it right
okay so left shifts at 8:00 right shifts
to so you can probably see that the
number actually doubled when we shift to
the left and it haft when we shifted it
right okay now that in mind you can
actually convert this bit shift into
just a normal mathematical operation
right and all this is really is a number
such as four yeah and all you're doing
is in this case in terms of a left shift
you're actually multiplying it right by
two to the power of the number of places
that you're moving it so two to the
power of one in this case
okay it's a multiplying it by 2 to the
power of one results in a being 8 of
course and in this case you're doing the
same thing subdividing instead of
multiplying so in this case it's going
to be 4 divided by 2 to the power of 1
okay so 4 divided by 2 in that case will
be 2 okay so you can actually do this
with normal maths you don't need to do
this in binary in fact you can only do a
binary if you basically operating on
integers of course there's no such thing
you can't do this to like a float or
something but this is typically usually
more readable if you're actually doing
dealing with binary operations and if
you're do think what something like
color for example and you're extracting
channels and we'll talk about that
because there's a great example of
binary then and you and you want to
shift left by like 24 places obviously
you know instead of that if you wrote
multiply it by 2 to the power of 20
for that would be huge number that's
just not gonna look too clean so anyway
that's what bad shifting does very
simple just shift the bits like if you
had more complicated examples like this
for example and you decided to shift
that left three places for example that
would kind of overflow in this case but
if you if your integer was big enough to
store it then it would look something
like you might have one one zero zero
zero right so you would shift it left
three spaces and you would wind up with
whatever you get okay similarly if you
try and continue shifting it right
you'll eventually just hit zero okay
because you will run out of places so
anyway that's how that works
it's pretty it's pretty simple honestly
and it's really not anything that you
guys probably couldn't have understood
if you just looked it up because it's
really it's really quite simple and it
doesn't take too much time to learn now
where I see most of these videos failing
is in explaining how this is useful
because it's great knowing that oh yeah
I know how this works so if I see this
in code I've been recognized of what it
does and I can you know work it out yeah
sure that's not really particularly
difficult to do is it the problem comes
from hey how can I use this and why
would I even want to use this anywhere
okay so that's what we're actually going
to talk about right now because it's
very important to to cover that so we're
actually gonna do some programming
finally so this is the deal right
the first thing I'm gonna write is a as
a function called prints
okay and this is going to take in like a
number essentially and I'm going to
output it in a special way I'm going to
output it as a print F okay and I'm
gonna set the format to be hexadecimal
all right that's all I'm doing
so the reason I'm doing this is because
it's a great way for us to just quickly
print something as hex of course is
going to be a void method all right
now you can actually print stuff in
binary as well so I might do something
like private static void print bin or
something and then this will just do a
normal
system that are online but it will do
integer dot two binary string value
alright so this way we can now print
both hexadecimal and binary if we need
to okay and then even change to
something like print hex alright cool so
let's get right on into this so the
first thing we learned about was anding
and we'll talk about how that can be
useful so if we have a value for example
and but one thing I should mention is
this is much easier to do if you're
actually in hexadecimal land because if
you're in hexadecimal and then each
digit is 4 bits of course I think kind
of all lines up nicely
because you know what you're doing if
it's if you kind of start writing values
like TV g5 instead of FF then you're
going to run into trouble
anyway suppose we have a value such as
you know we've got like a color for
example well let's just say we've got
1234 like I said this is our footer ok
so right now this is quite a large value
if which tried to print it or something
as a normal decimal we would get
something like four six six zero right
if we print it has a hex then of course
we should expect to get the exact same
thing that we entered and there you go
however what if we wanted to for example
extract part of this so you can see that
this is two bytes yeah it would be
pretty useful for us to maybe split this
up into two actual Veit values okay
because if we're outputting it for
example into I don't know
just into a file and we want to
precisely right the bytes or something
we might want to split this up into two
bytes for example so how can we do that
well a good way to do this is by using
bitwise operators okay so this is where
anding and shifting comes into play it's
the first thing we can do to it is we
can actually use the and operator to
extract parts if it's all called as
variable a and essentially it will be
our value okay and 0xff okay so what I'm
doing is I'm ending this by essentially
a full set of bits so if we go back to
the drawing board
for second and suppose we have like ffs
essentially which is equal to 255 in
binary is expressed as 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
bits okay so it's a full bottom ones now
we've learned that by ending anything by
1 is really the only reason by the way
if you and anything by one you will get
one ok which means that if we have a
number that's just 1 0 1 0 1 0 1 0 for
example and we end this by a series of
ones like that then the result we will
get in this case is actually just this
top number okay because ending anything
by by 1 will give you basically the
original result so 1 + 1 is gonna be 1 0
+ 1 is going to be 0 and it's going to
kind of continue like this and there you
go right we've got that same number we
had at the top in the result okay so
this is this is what's called a mask as
well it's called a mask because it lets
us kind of select a region of numbers
because let's just say that we wanted to
select a particular region of this
number for example we just wanted the
bottom bytes or the bottom bits rather
so what we could do is if we had this
long number and we just wanted to select
this region we could add it by 0 0 0 0 1
1 1 1 which would mean the result we
would get obviously this is all this is
all gonna result in 0 which just cancels
out right it is all 0 and then of course
this will give us 1 0 1 0 ok this is
what bit masking is it's very useful
because it lets us select essentially
regions of bits and discard other bits
ok
so cool in this case if we were to print
something like this and again we're
adding this number by FF we would get
something like
well like that first involves I was
actually pretty number well guess I'm
like 34 so you can see we've managed to
extract this bit which is pretty cool
right because what we've essentially
done better way to write this might be
something like 0 0 FF which doesn't
actually do anything but it kind of
helps us you can see that we've got this
number and essentially we have ended it
by this number okay and you can see that
now I've kind of got the digits lighting
up these two things kind of cancel out
because they get added with 0 just like
I showed you in our example over here
and then in this case the FF of course
means it's just a full bit of one so
whatever is here will just get pushed
down and that'll be a result which is
what our result is okay pretty cool now
we've managed to extract this part of
the number but how do we extract this
part of the number that's the question
right it's actually not that simple
because if we try and do something like
FF 0 0 which is what you would logically
think we would get 1200 in hex rather
than just 12 because we really just want
12 right and that's because of course by
adding it we're kind of reducing this to
0 but since the digits we want are
basically followed by a bunch of zeros
right there in front of a bunch of zeros
does really mean something when we have
like leading zeros they don't mean
anything we're gonna have a million
zeros in our number and the number is
still going to be 1200 right however
when we have trailing zeros they
obviously increase our number ok so
there we go that's our number how do we
get how do we just get the 12 and that's
where bit shifting comes into play so
imagine you had this scenario but the
other way around so we had 1 0 1 0 1 0 1
0 and we ended it by 1 1 1 1 and then 0
0 0 0 right this would give us 1 0 1 0
with a bunch of zeros which is basically
what what we've ended up with so what we
really want to do is take this and we
want to shift it that way
ok so in this case if you count it 1 2 3
4 we need to shift it 4 bits to the left
sorry to the right right so we shifted 4
it's to the right and that of course if
we do something like that then we will
end up with one zero one zero and that's
it okay done because this entire thing
will move four bits so that being said
let's do that so if we had something
like this in this case which we have to
move it eight bits because where this is
like a full byte but if we do something
like this so if we were to add it by
that and then shift it right eight bits
and then the value that we would get
would be just twelve there you go all
right pretty cool so you'll see this
stuff all the time and stuff like color
for example so if we had a color and one
of my favorite colors is pink so this is
what pink looks like each byte here this
is a 24-bit color each byte here is a
separate color Channel so obviously this
is dependent on how you interpret the
color but in this case we've got RGB
where the first two well the first two
digits here or the first byte is the
most significant byte is red the middle
byte here is green and then the least
significant byte is blue all right so
we've got a we've got a color here and
then I might want to extract this in
terms of RGB right I want to have three
separate variables that are rjb how can
I do that well I would encourage you
guys to have a go right now off before I
do and just test out because everything
I told you right now should should apply
to this so I'll give you a minute now
that you're hopefully done pause the
video have to go and let's take a look
at the answer so red okay will be
something along the lines of color and 0
at 0 X ff0000
so we're selecting just this part here
so now this result right now would give
us that because we're just we're ending
this entire thing like this right now we
need to shift it right
so we shift it right 24 so 16 bits okay
and that what's up with being over here
all right
G Oh green is going to be pretty much
the same except we're going to
and what we're going to end it by that
and then we're going to shift it only
eight places and then blue finally is
going to be pretty simple it's just
going to be color and FF like that
shifted nowhere okay so you can write
that which of course translates into
divided by two to the power of zero
which of course equals just divided by 1
because 2 to the power 0 is 1 which
would be nothing so you can leave that
there if you like or you can get rid of
it ok so now that we've got this if we
were to print ah that's not going to
work
RGB then we would get into we would get
FF 0 0 + FF okay so 255 0 255 there we
go so we've separated this color into a
bunch of into a bunch of integers pretty
awesome stuff so now let's talk about
how we can actually reassemble that
color so how can we do the reverse of
what we just did we managed to extract
this but how do we put it back in to
what it was right that's also something
useful so for example in this case let's
just say that we were we had a number
and we were trying to like reduce its
brightness or something so we decided to
do something like once we have the
channels we subtracted like I don't know
10 from it or something ok this will
give us a negative number in this case
so pretend that we just had it like a
check here that set of where it was less
than zero green equals zero or something
like that so we won't do anything for
that but let's just say we do something
like this right and then we wanted to
reassemble the color obviously because
we wanted it in this format again in a
single integer so how can we do that
well this involves basically the reverse
of this so this is where our ordering
situation comes into practice so this is
where we use all and we also need to use
a left bit shift so those are the two
things those the two things we'll be
using
so the first thing we need to do is
actually shift that color back into
place or that value back into place so
it needs to be where it was before okay
the way we can do that it's just simply
by taking something like so if we have
our result here we can take something
like the our variable and then shift it
left 16 places that put that puts it
back into place
so if we were to print something like
this we would get CD and then a bunch of
values so CD because we've of course
reduced by 50 if we didn't do that we
would get a normal FF but you can see
it's followed by a bunch of zeros cool
so we're kind of done here but then wait
we also want these bits to be whatever
Green is so legit just for lulz here
let's increase green by like 10 or
something so that's just so that it's
not or even something like I don't know
28 so that is not just zero zero if we
have something like this how do we also
put the green into this variable because
right this is an integer so we can
actually store something in these in
these in this by and we can store
something in this by it so how do we do
that
that's where the ore comes into place
okay so back to the drawing board what
we're doing now is essentially we've
wound up with a number such as FF and
then you can see we've got a bunch of
zeros at the end here okay so if I were
to expand this it would be essentially
sixteen ones followed by 25 32 zeros
right which we're not really interested
in hint drawing I want to draw that many
digits but basically the idea with this
is that once we've got something like
this and we want to combine it with
something like for example the thing we
want to really combine it with is like
legends pretend it's FF 0 0 and we'll
just put zeros here just for the sake of
flying up right we just want to combine
these and we really want to get FF FF 0
0 right how can we do that well it's
very simple because we can do that with
the or operator okay obviously if we
have something like if we broke this
down into binary just so you guys can
see and we have something really simple
like that yeah we know from these rules
for that
one or zero is still one okay so we can
combine sections of numbers essentially
by using the or operator
okay so 101 is 1 101 is 1 1 0 1 is 1 and
0 1 is 1 ok so there we go we've got 1 1
1 1 exactly what we needed here okay
done and we can do the same thing for
the blue channel as well obviously if
you have something like you might have
23 or 48 you're not you're going to get
something different I can't it's going
to depend on what the binary it was that
makes this up but for stuff like 0 or a
value it will always be a value so if
you did something like 10 23 or 0 sorry
23 or 1 for example you would get that
I'm sorry let me do this probably 23 or
0 yeah we'll give you 23 ok because any
bits that were set will remain set ok
and then if you ever put a 1 here then I
would add bits is actually like you see
here we did a 1 an added bit ok cool
very very simple stuff so now we can
just simply say orgy shifted at left 8
or be ok and if we were to prints out it
gives us our assembled result which
without this stuff would look something
like this right which is what we started
with and if we put anything here like 1
2 3 4 5 6
for example you can see that we end up
with that result
cool so we have successfully learned
about bit shifting and bit masking and
the reverse for that which is assembling
everything back together cool so how's
this going to be useful for us in our in
our civilization format and whatnot so
let's talk about that now quickly so
first of all I just want to show you
guys in binary this color would look
something like this right that's what I
didn't want to draw so you can see we've
got 8 bits of one a bunch of zeros and
then eight bits of one again so when we
do something like
this red thing
then we wound up with just this now
there are like a bunch of leading zeros
pretend so this is like kind of a line
to this side so you can see week since
they extracted the red Channel and then
of course this will actually be the same
as the blue channel in this case right
you can see these two are identical okay
cool
two things I want to cover quickly there
are essentially the let me just get at
its color example just the exclusive-or
and the other thing so if we have
something like a number exclusive or not
here's what I wanted to color so we have
a number of bits like 0 X 1 2 right in
binary this is going to be a invited is
gonna look like this right if I were to
exclusive or something like we had
another number here which was like 24 or
something I don't know I'm making stuff
up and we were to is this is not going
to be exclusive o'red well I shouldn't
double that let's just say hey it'll
work well I think or not um 7 sure so if
we were to exclusive all these two
together
then we would actually get so it's going
to be a and then the Hat which is above
this 6k and then B alright we would
basically get the reverse of that or
rather not the reverse of that but we
would get a 1 if there were the same so
to break this down for you quickly cuz
it's a bit hard to tell with the
alignment we basically had that we order
it with that which of course is aligned
like that because these two are zeros
and then we got 1 0 1 0 1 right these
two is you can see a unique so we got a
1 these two are not unique so we got a 0
these two are unique so we got a 1 1 and
1 of course are the same they're not
exclusive so we got a 0 and a 0 why
don't we got one okay there you go
that's how exclusive or what
and it is quite useful as well all right
finally we have the moss which is just a
squiggly line in an a you can see what
that did
it's a bit difficult to really
understand what it did unless you happen
to understand it I guess so you can see
that it did actually reverse it we did
it to a so you can see that if you
copied and pasted this number you will
see that the difference between these
two is that it basically just flipped
every bit right and then it added a
whole bunch of once the reason they did
that is because we're dealing with a
32-bit integer integer type so really
what you had of course is just this that
that's what this looks like in memory
okay so there those all got flipped into
ones if you reduce the type of something
like a short or a vice and you try and
flip it you'll get a smaller number or
as you should maybe not short hmm that's
a bit weird
ah it's because it's taking it in it so
if we make it take in not an ends like
advice for example so it was implicitly
casting over there so this is going to
yell at you apparently am i preaching
binary what's wrong with the arts
integer - binary string as well that's
probably not great this is gonna be a
bit difficult to print but if you do
something like a short and then you may
be printed in hex
so we print for that in hacks man all
right
more costing apparently then you can say
that will only get kind of those things
at it we could probably do this with a
bite to be honest yeah somewhat pretty
out of that anyway I guess that is that
yeah I'm not sure what it did that well
I actually do not want to do that so
much casting still doing that there we
go Edie right so if we had something
like what something that you can easily
flip F 0 will get 0 F or if we had 0 F
rather we might get F 0 yeah so it just
flips it okay that's what not does cool
alright all that aside how can we use
this in our formats well this is the
deal right it comes to us being able to
convert to and from certain values so if
we have something like it's actually
this is I'm not gonna have time to do
this right now so I'm going to have to
leave this for the next episode I didn't
explain this to go for so long and I
have to get to work because it's not
ahem anyway I hope you guys enjoyed this
video next time we're going to actually
take a look at how this will work in
asteroid agent library and will
basically write a utils class which will
implement a lot of these operations to
and from binary conversion from various
different data types okay and then we'll
take a look at how that data will be
represented in memory and in our actual
file ok so if you guys into this video
please hit the like button you can
support me on patreon home for the
channel if you enjoyed these videos and
you are a super fan and of course don't
forget to join the slack channel so I've
got the turn home if you want to engage
into some real time messaging with the
entire channel community so thanks for
watching guys hit a like button if you
enjoyed and I will see you guys next
time goodbye